Так. Загалом, окреслено що ми залучаємо ми будемо робити а це у нас сьогодні кінець.
Як було зазначено на минулому складати що це означає, ми оглянемо 2 елементи класичні Перший елемент огляд впритул або з при інтерв'ю тобто ми оглянемо як експеримент пройшов чи можливо, ми взяли забагато завдань, який прогрес взагалі по завданні поглянемо а що вам це
наприклад, зараз на занятті. В нас не є присутні з обох команд Спершу, команда навіть не повна тому я думаю, що цілком резонно.
п'ятницю.
Тому у вас є думаю, цілком буде час, тоді ми можемо якраз саме почати з огляду сприйнято я зараз відкрию асану.
І поки що в нас лише перша команда тому будемо працювати з першу команду. Якщо приєднається з другої команди, також цілком можемо спробувати але поки що почнемо так так секунду.
Так, Дякую. Нам буде гарно. Видно.
проєкт. Ти.
Я думаю, що ми цілком можемо зараз Якщо ви знаєте, хто над чим займається ми можемо цілком зараз спробувати доєднати завдання. До того, хто їх виконує.
No, yes, now it's your Elizabeth Alexandro known as robotic.
Добре. Так. Це будете Ось ви Так, монстро-педію.
Monstropédio.
Це яке саме завдання, нас буде наприклад.
Little design monstroposizing. Rosropa design.
Добре Ми зараз. Загалом. Розподіляємо завдання. Щоб було зрозуміло.
Так? Стосовно дизайн велосипед не розумію як сторінка блогу.
Сапки блогу, яку саме частину.
Тобто сторінка конкретного застосування блогу.
Можливо, тоді доцільно додати завдання, якщо воно вже виконане і вказати реального виконавця.
Хто?
Yeah, that's nice.
Ж.
зафіксувати тобто у нас через те, що це був як то кажуть перший такий варіант, не всі завдання могли бути ось так, на 2 тижні, ми чітко бачимо ви бачите що певні речі.
Там з'явилися щось додалося, давайте спробуємо Отже, Павло Володимирович.
Ви якраз проходите по завданнях, можливо, як то кажуть, з самого початку, що в нас було тобто репутаторів гідхаб був обурений І якщо не помиляюсь, зі Станіславом андрійовичем.
В.
Так.
Чи я помиляюсь?
Ми створювали так Але минулі парі. Але самі ще Ні, ще не я створив.
А водночас ви з творів ви створили свій репозитарій саме відповідний проєкт я правильно розумію.
Ну поки. Поки. Так.
Якщо так! Давайте запишемо що оце завдання. Було виконане не і виконане вами.
Так тут. Ми вказали ми вказали і перетягуємо просто зробимо і Загалом, користувача.
Тобто фізики.
Історію. Я Тепер перетягую також що вона зроблена як всі завдання, історії виконані далі в нас, йде розробка дизайну шапки.
Блогу.
Ну це ж у мене на головній сторінці там я і шапка і вже чого там тільки нема.
Добре тоді у вас.
Чудово. Ставимо відповідального і ставимо що це Наразі в нас є виконана.
Ця частина виконана так.
Ну Так.
Чудово тоді переміщаємо і підтягуємо також і користувацьку історію бачите вже 5 завдань.
Зроблено Так, лише наступне в нас Перенесення дизайну шапки. Сайту програми: частин це яке Розміщення не було зроблено.
Ну, ми вирішили спочатку ми зробимо повністю дизайн, а потім вже тобто будуть якось це реалізовувати.
Добре. Тоді я назад? Користувацький торт. Як це завдання, пов'язане з це як користувацької історії.
Тому нам ще потрібно ось це тоді розробка дизайну, сторінки, блоку який розуміється також ви розробляєте, так добре, тоді це перетягуємо процес, розробки і наскільки я розумію ще 1 дизайн, розробляється так.
Так.
Добре тоді ми можемо створити завдання Загалом, для того, щоб розуміти який прогрес, що тоді конкретно як можемо назвати завданням.
Але.
У Розробка дизайну монстрапедії Чи щось у цьому сенсі.
Так. Так. Так.
Алло Монстрок.
Ми просто вирішили це як окремо сторінку зробити?
Не знаю, чи це доцільно, чи ні, що скажете.
А цілком Тобто, тут вам. Ніхто не забороняє. Частину робити. Ви цілком можете розробляти так?
Як ви бачите це за потрібне і я думаю, що це досить гарний те, і хто виконавець.
Нагадайте, Ще раз.
Ліза від збереження.
п я не бачу, щоб вони були не занять тому поки що не можемо з ними, працювати я думаю, якщо ця частина тоді готова ви можете показати дизайн ми поглянули що на даному етапі розратуно.
Так, зараз Ну, у мене таке зараз покажу.
просто настати.
Тобто, питання. Чи це багато сторінковий сайт чи це односторінковий привітно за реалізацію Ну, як замовнику?
Так. Так.
замість того, всі як то кажуть посилання для переходу.
Я можу просто бути Знаєте, типу швидше, щоб не шукати Оце самому де воно там, знаходиться а так швидко натиснула і вона одразу переходить може воно там, в самому кінці і треба буде до кінця листати.
Так, можливо, так, зробити щоб оці Посилання вони були закріплені на вершині відповідної сторінки і тоді можна було б не доцільним чином, організовувати чи це скролік чи то перехід це на ваш розсуд тоді.
Добре, добре, тоді обговоримо це з командою, що вони захочуть, як захочуть, хлопці, бо вони ж це будуть робити?
Ну, тут можливо як то, кажуть, враховуючи що хлопці, тут є відповідна частина обговорити навіть в контексті застосування не конкретного фримворку який власне, тут може бути до вашої роботи.
Перепрошую, Павло Володимирович. Я маю Наразі збігати у приймальню.
Зраз.
5 хвилин, змушений відключитися тоді передаю вам функції замовника тимчасово, а далі. Будемо як то кажуть: з цим розбиратися вибачте будь ласка, Так!
Добре, так можливо, тоді станіслав якщо є можливість обрали все ж таки щось, технологія, а конкретно за допомогою чого ви хочете розробляти тому що я бачу я думаю, що він буде схожий до або до арт-пресу наприклад, тут і не більше.
Власним тому які є пропозиції, стосовно того, що ви плануєте брати.
що тому можливо, вікс ми зробили так що поки обирати вікс якщо будуть якісь проблеми з реалізацією, намагатися бистенько перейти до якогось фемвоку ну ти потім того ж джанго на пайту ні або.
Дивіться, тут частина, яку добре було порахувати. Це те, що навіть в даному дизайні.
Ну або то ми.
У вас наприклад, будуть користувачі в монстрапеді Так, і вам треба їхати з перших не впевнений, стосовно як вікс пропонує чи вони взагалі пропонують можна зараз Звісно, глянути, чи взагалі пропонується ресурси в плані, постане Тобто, вам потрібна бути база даних, які вам треба?
Агу.
Буде навчати зберігати користувачі Тобто чи вікс у даному випадку вам підійде питання хоча б безкоштовна версія тому що тут я думаю, це і буде проблема що чи безкоштовна версія включає у цьому випадку таку вакцину Тобто коли у вас іде розробка більш чогось конкретно.
Турецький це також треба приховати тому що поки що з того, що я бачив взагалі не бачу в кса безкоштовний версій в них є наскільки я бачу, лише лайт.
Яка працює лише для двох співавторів, тобто і вона досить така, виглядає.
Звично але знову ж таки, я тут можливо, визнаю за бази даних. Чи є підтримка у.
Ну, це Я трішки не недо впевнений. Зріс бази даних.
Ну, а тому треба врахувати цей також момент, ми загалом сьогодні, також як частину заняття розглянемо більш практично абстракт, Тобто, як можна швиденько побудувати Ну, звичайний вебсайт, скажемо там за 30 хвилин.
безкоштовною і знову ж таки, мало часу, то через криптіх загалом досить велика кількість не можна завантажити тому я не думаю, що це буде така ж проблема.
досить легко витягти те, що зроблено навіть в даному вигляді і Загалом, зробити щось такого ось вокальна вероніка досить буде я думаю, що легко.
Тому що ви думаєте, стосовно? Цього?
Ну так там є такі фільми який показує всі стилі я точно не пам'ятаю але знаю, що 100, проценту, таки є голову.
Ну, а тому я б рекомендував вам все ж таки такий варіант просто з того що вікс вас може, дуже легко.
Були були У нас із сімей. Тисих.
штучним інтелектом, то це буде також досить зробити.
Добре. Тоді я думаю, що ми можемо якраз прийти до погляду. У путстрапі Загалом, зрозуміти, що це таке я зазначу, декілька варіантів.
Тобто, якщо ви там. Хочете використовувати реакцію, або якщо ви хочете використовувати в'ю наприклад, взагалі навіщо нам це буде потрібно просто такі бібліотеки.
І яка з них користь?
Так. Зараз тоді.
Я покажу демонстрацію крану у кно але хочу сказати що гарний прогрес у вас вже є я думаю, що дизайн це дуже добре, тому я думаю, що цілком добре, плану йде?
Так, тоді переходимо ось сюди. Чудово. Так, видно ванка.
Видно.
Добре загалом що ви представляє будз можливо, взагалі ви чули про нього на своїх заняттях чи ні.
Власний досвід.
Так? Загалом. Що з собою представляє давайте коротенько пройдемося це фактично просто збірка вже готових елементів.
Реальність така, що якщо ви навіть працювати над комерційними проєктами, розробка дизайну з нуля, займає дуже велику кількість часу.
Це Є проблематично декількох аспектів. Перше, це те, що це є досить складно.
посилання ви можете також поглянути.
Так. Ось це посилання Буд Строк? Ви можете поглянути що він собою представляє комітет.
Ось такий Ось Базовий приклад. Тобто, він не є ні з чим. Складним, це просто лише базова структура, яку ми можемо скопіювати а фактично, бобстра додається за допомогою двох рядків коду, це додавання стилів.
7-тесу відбудсстрапу і додавання деякого функціоналу піджаласкрипту тобто 2 рядки і ви фактично можете підключити основу будьстрапу.
Давайте роз перш ніж будемо все ж таки стрибати до розробки ми глянемо, що з тобою, взагалі представляє якщо підемо, до більш конкретного ось бачимо що у нас є форми і ми клікаємо переглянути і вони пропонують нам декілька вже з готових елементів, наприклад, форм контролю.
Або селект і глянемо, наприклад, форм контрол точно бачите що за допомогою восьми рядків воду ми можемо створити ось такий гарний дизайн з фактично вже готовими елементами які є стилізованим тут бачите обираєте наприклад, текстове поле для бедення і воно у нас
з'являється підсвітка так само, як і ось тут і фактично це робиться досить просто як ви бачите, тобто це звичайний імпульс і все що робиться це просто йому ставиться ось такий клас з форум контрол, який і надає йому ось такого зовнішнього вигляду так є багато прикладів.
можемо бачити стилізувати конкретні елементи тобто у нас дуже велика кількість прикладів, яка тут є яку ми можемо використовувати цілком.
була ситуацію. Наприклад, в нас є Фактично, Ось, бачите такі елементи, які представляють перевізно кольорові з текстом.
енергіаційний Барбачте, ось готовий. Вже Фактично, або навіть дуже простенький приклад.
потрібно і ви можете просто його копіювати і використовувати Загалом, ще глянемо одну частинку звідси.
Буд штрафу є дуже корисною частина це приклади чому я б радий вам звернути на них увагу це Тому що приклади дозволяють нам глянути на Ось такі готові вже дизайн тобто ми натиснемо хедерс зволок.
елементами і логотип Тобто, фактично тут можна змінювати все, що завгодно і можна буде переглянути ми до цього елементу трошки пізніше.
Поки що повернемось і давайте все ж таки спробуємо розробити щось повертаючись до сторінки яка показується нам говорять що створюють навички індексичний файл у вашому проєкті, і ось додайте ось такий ось от зараз я змінюю трошки налаштування.
Екрану, так. Ось так. Має бути я думаю.
А добре Так, Очевидно, вам екран. Зараз весь А має зараз видно по віжул-студіо.
А что а дивіться Тобто, я тут вже створив Але давайте все ж таки і дала нам цей файл Взагалі те, що нам потрібен і це прибирає Тобто, це репертуар який у нас лишився з минулого заняття.
Так. Видно.
І з кліка створити новий файл підписуємо тут Індексиччина це компанія консула його назві вона може бути і будь-якою але ми повертаємось ось до цього копіюємо з тих частин.
Або можна обвести і все скопіювати або можете натиснути сюди, скопіювати і повертаємось до.
Біжустудюк вставляємо зберігаємо і от у нас такий дуже базовий приклад як добре для того, щоб нам його відкрити нам треба його все ж таки відкрити браузер це може зробити декількома шляхами, загалом вам просто треба буде відкрити цей репозиторій так на секунду, зупиню зараз.
Ага. Має працювати все ж таки, не має бути проблеми так секунду.
А.
Так. Є.
потрібно відкриває ми бачимо, що в нас тут вло воду. Подивіться, але поки що постраждав.
нашого Так, як бачите, на даний момент нам треба буде кожен раз встановлювати екран.
Але ось поки що в нас філовороту відновлюємо екран і Бачите, те, що Коловорот змінився.
Тобто це означає, що успішно вод страп все ж таки має так свої стилі, вже в нашому проєкті, чудово, і все як говорить третя частина просто відкрити цю сторінку, обра браузерів і працюйте з нею.
Тобто ця частина в нас вже готова тут штраф, підключено і ми на це витратили мабуть, Хвилинку.
набагато простіше, все ж таки додамо от ось такий дуже схожий до того що в нас є копіюємо весь код, який тут є скопіювали дотаємно.
Зберігаємо і переходимо назад до образи оновлюємо і бачите що ось нас.
З'явилося Так, я думаю, що перетягну його трошки зараз секунду. Ось так ну, з'явився такий навігаційний бар зверх і він чудовий!
Виглядає Тобто бачити нас дуже швидко, і можемо для прикладу, так як ми все ж таки, працюємо лише з першої групи там нозема Монстрапедія.
Ановимо і ось у нас є якась конструкція. Тут можна і логотип додати і ще ж кажемо що ми хочемо змінювати колір так для кольорів у нас є тут спеціальні якимось тобто допоміжні всякі методи і тут є ось той крау чудово.
І в нас є ось різні параграунди нут які ми хочемо якщо подивимось то в нас тут вказаний осінь в елементі нам для навігації, в нас тут вказаний елемент пічі боді тийки це фактично у нас ось цей елемент скажемо що я хочу щось темніше, я копіюю його і додаю до класу.
Пановлює і бачите, в нас наприклад, тепер так, це навігаційний бар став сірого кольору, Тобто, досить чудово.
Досить просто і взагалі неважко змінити. Щось скажемо що ми наприклад, тепер хочемо зробити основне тіло нашого сайту.
Для цього нам потрібно повертаємось трошки вверх. А в нас тут є лояльно це фактично те, як ви будете розташовувати елементи це розташування елементів на вашому сайті ми хочемо в каннах.
частини зберігаємо.
А і оновлюємо ось бачите, у нас ось для того, щоб розуміти краще як він взагалі виглядає якийсь.
Так здається табу в праймері Ну, ось бачите тобто ми додали якийсь елемент з таким жахливим, побігалодом, але це просто для розуміння що це взагалі у нас буде тобто якщо ми збільшуємо.
До ексалю то це його змі при деяких екранах наприклад, якщо ми змінюємо в даному випадку, не змінимо тому що воно вже займає максимум свого екран тому ми можемо просто фактично і використати контейнер, У цьому випадку, пес потреби під якийсь більше.
навколо. Ми вказуємо в мінус 2 Давайте спробуємо додати в мінус 3.
Я скажу хочу Так, повернемось до нашого будстра. Елементу. І ось бачимо, що він нас дуже добре, тепер трошки краще.
вліво. Вони це називають Старт або N кінець або ж Ви прочите Так, це для правого лівого і ігри це для верху.
додати там пости по прикладу, того, що у вас є або прикладу того, що загалом я постраждали дуже чудовий інструмент який нам саме таки дозволяє розташовані елементи дуже просто пес, великої потреби так це в нас має бути Ну, секунду.
Ось тут. Це називається ґріт або сітка. Фактична система. Сіток вони використовують флекси можливо, вам знайомі елементи вже Тобто що це взагалі навіщо воно взагалі потрібне це потрібно для того, щоб розташовувати елементи в колонки.
буде підчила. Спробуємо їх дуже Легко змінювати. Не треба підбирати. Кольори.
Тепер у нас зливається до що це заднім фону тому було б добре можливо ось такий ось.
Менш помітний, але все ж таки, Ну не дуже добре, давайте спробуємось такий.
Змінили. І Непогано. То виглядає щось схоже, до того, що він хоче бачити бачите у нас є 3 колонки.
Монополії переглядати от скажемо Ми хочемо 2 рядки в 3 киточніше.
І в кожному рядку по 2 елементи.
От, бачите і вони в нас розтягуються ось Так Ну, для прикладу давайте додамо що у кожного рядка був.
Колір вечі правий щоб ми бачимо, бачите що вони йдуть 1 за одним. Ну, хочемо, ми скажемо, між ними простір для цього ми можемо вказати є дуже велику кількість різних елементів, але фактично знову ж таки, ми й додаткові методи і скажемо там спейс надто тут вказуються.
У нас різні приклади, і Ми хочемо кек коли ми говорять, що коли ви використовуєте гарієт ви можете вказувати ось цей елемент, ке Давайте спробуємо, читати це працювати в нашому методі, в нашому випадку як то якийсь там вказував працює тому що як вказували використовують
Флекс ось у нас з'явився простір між двома елементами. Чудово. Тобто спробуємо додати це тепер до кожного рядку щоб вони виглядали дуже схоже Бачите, у нас Тепер є між ними.
карта Знову ж таки, просто копіюємо.
зробити. Ми переходимо до нам тут потрібен плес. Це Ось такий Ось елемент тут вказують нам як працювати з ними Загалом, і знову ж таки, ви можете пошукати в Інтернеті.
Лекції досить популярним і ось тут у нас є різні приклади Отже, співають контент розташувальний контент.
Скажемо, я хочете щоб весь контент? Був Ну, по центру?
Додаємо Все Флакс Нам не потрібен танули тому спробуємо додати не працюю правий за флексом.
От тепер працю.
Додаємо це і до іншого у нас є вже чудова частина бачите, у нас є 2 картки, які можуть бути елементами, сайту.
Скажемо І вони зцентровані. І вони є досить гарно. Виглядають Давайте спробуємо зробити те ж саме для інших.
Двох Це рядки.
Щось, такого типу: і в нас є досить чудово що виглядає.
3 таких Ось елементи в кожному рядку. Економічному стовпчику. І ті хто ж легко можна використав спробуємо все ж таки бачити у нас, між ними.
Немає. Місце. Спробуй ми додати. Якесь Місяця?
Далі А знову ж таки, Йдемо до спейсиг і шукаємо бо в нас є ровке тобто між рядками.
Простір справи Бачите, буде працювати в нашому випадку нам треба це додати до елементу, який є контейнери.
Тому, що нам треба щоб він охоплював сі рядки, тут Звернемо і ось у нас 3 рядка, тобто, нам треба батьківські елементи дати проблем. Спробуємо на жаль, не працює а Погляньмо в чому проблема скоріш за все нам треба додати на нього ось таке.
Але паргляну Так, от Бачите скопіювали мене. Дивилися всі сес дуже сильно і в нас такий базовий приклад вийшов який легко можна реалізуватися.
Самостійно. Якщо ми хочемо щось змінити. Хочу вам додати щось до цієї кнопки або після ці кнопки.
бургера Але, немає. На жаль, все ж таки йдемо, до працівників, і в нас є бачите, тут одразу як ми пішли завантажити приклади ми їх завантажуємо і можемо відкривати так одну секунду я їх спробую знайти.
Залежно від не впевнений, що в мене є завантажені, тому можна тут і завантажити критий код.
можемо так? Можна винніти і ось ми відкриваємо дивимось що нам треба з прикладів.
Ну мені потрібно Хеберт, Я хочу знайти Хедерс знайшов Хедерс і Глянемо, що в нас є по прикладах, так оберемо спробуємо відкрити Валерій і ось у нас дуже Чудово, відкрився.
Я хочу вкрасти ось цей елемент профілю так. Нам його Дякую. Ідентифікувати ну можна пошукати.
2 інтерв'ю.
іспіювати. От Ми захотіли змінити навігаційний баз копіюємо приклад.
сюди от чудово і в нас додам і знову ж таки, можемо міняти Монстрапедія змінили От у нас є в гостропаді тобто ось таким чином, можна фактично бачите зараз ми побудували за півгодинки з врахуванням.
монстрапеді натискаючи воно Звісно, скидає до репозиторів, тому нам це не потрібно тому ми можемо поки що це прибрати але загалом бачите, у нас досить швидко просто.
Вийшов такий звичайнісінький сайт я думаю, що було б добре, можливо, хтось у вас працює з комп'ютером, на даний момент ми могли б спробувати і має віл-студію звісно, ми могли б спробувати з вами підключити Ну, і там якийсь приклад, скажемо, запустити.
Можливо, станіслав може тому що пам'ятаю, що минулого разу, у вас був доступ Ну, Визвіл студію, котову можна було б спробувати якщо є можливість.
Мабуть, станіслав можливо, проблеми із зв'язком.
На вероніку можливо, у вас тоді, є встановлений візок.
Є встановлений.
Якщо не проти можемо, з вами, спробувати тоді підключити ось вказувати бо штраф і скажімо, якісь елементи, скопіювати.
Давайте спробуємо.
Добре так я припиняю демонстрацію. І ви можете спробувати почати?
Так, мені демонструвати. Весь екран Так.
Так щоб можна було бачити і що буде конкретно, на сайті і що тут буде розробляти все, в віжул студіокот.
Так. А сайти.
Так поки що ми будемо працювати ну з базою версією локально і ось натиснути можете ню файл новий файл і ось тут або тут так і надавайте назву індекс крапкищина.
Енту.
Поверніться в папку Де збережено цей Чите-файл відкрити його і вас він повинен відкритися на чудово бачите, по прикладу у нас є якийсь базовий хлобору і ми витратили з вами на це дуже хвилину, небагато.
Ну давайте спробуємо тепер додати по тому ж приклад якийсь навігаційний парк. Так, повертається до будстра і трошки нижче.
Опускайтесь до компонентів.
Трошки. Нижче, це не ті там малі має бути таким жирним, виділено Ні, бокові панелі ви Все правильно, робили просто воно.
Та Отут повинно було бути.
Нижче так? Ось Є компонент. Тут і тут вам треба знайти навба от, є в нас навпаки, тобто просто знаходити потрібний елемент, ви тут можете прогортати і бачите є такий приклад.
А.
Можете скопіювати його можете поглянути який вам інший подобається, і його скопіювати.
Так. Його Можете додати замість Бачите? У вас їхало? Угору?
На десятому рядку питають 10 рядок можете прибрати і сюди, вставити все щоб скопіював от Зберігайте і Давайте спробуємо поглянути що в нас вийшло.
От бачите, у нас вийшов. Дуже простенько швидкий навігаційний функціонал у ньому звісно ж, немає але частину. Дизайну.
Можна зробити Ну, Давайте спробуємо змінити назву на пару. До монстро-педії наприклад, або навіть можемо додати до нього і конку, але давайте поки що спробуємо змінити.
Назву шукайте просто дуже базу потрібно моніторити Так, зберігаєте.
От і в нас все. Є вже бачите в анстропеді наскільки я пам'ятаю, вашому прикладі, не було з цих кнопок Помлін богдан.
Давай їх Тоді прибере. Не потрібен.
І Якщо знаєте, Якщо це в менстрапедії окрема сторінка то може хом це як перехід на головну сторінку назад.
Цілком Тобто, можемо також давайте тоді перейменуємо кому в головностин так?
Головна може Ну, а в іншому ж не було обрати Тобто, у.
Так, категорій. Наприклад, можна назвати усю лінка.
Ну, Давайте спробуємо, поглянути що в нас вийшло.
Так. Завантажити і якщо опуститися трошки нижче то там будуть ось так бачите у нас тут є різні приклад, наприклад, ви можете додати собі хірурс.
Натисніть На нього. Та Хіба ж тут у нас тут є вже готові? Такі елементи ви можете це фактично скопіювати на головну сторінку якусь собі сформувати з цих елементів головну сторінку менстропеді з описом це менш стратегія для монстрів ми робимо ось таке Ну, Давайте спробуємо щось
скопіювати. Відкрийте Ось той архів який у вас завантажився.
Так.
Ре чудово? Відкрийте твердопатку яка у вас не в архіві.
Як мене, не розрахувався, чи що?
Мі розрахувалась він у нас Ось вас третім вказано так і шукаємо у нас тут має бути кіровс.
Мм. Бачу. Бачу.
Ось, воно і наприклад, бачите тут у нас тут є такі приклади. Знову ж таки, спробуйте ось бачите чудово відображалося Тепер вам треба його відкрити вжував студію.
Ага.
Ви можете так відкрити файл або відкрити папку Ну, тут залежить як буде зручно, можете хірурс.
Так. Воно. Має трошки. Ось є вибрати чи папку можете не виходити як Він мені мене цілком так?
А.
Воно вам агано відкрила в новому а от але фактично що вам треба індекс наприклад, ми хочемо у них є якісь стилі, але вони нам не дуже треба тут зверху у вас буде купа всяких елементів, ми їх поки що будемо ігнорувати проходьте вниз.
Ні.
І шукаємо, те, що нам потрібно саме ті елементи, які ми хотіли б вкрасти, звідси.
Так ще Йдемо вниз. Поки не побачимо. От у нас є якісь елементи, Ну, скажемо що ми хочемо перше Спробували.
Скопіювати весь елемент тому починаючи з дідів і давайте вниз допоки ми не побачимо де початок, я думаю, що ще можна цілком.
Ага. Це приклади. Вибачаюсь неправильними. Копіювали То просто була тема Тому трошки нижче.
Ні нижче і в нас бачите приклад із 172 до 180 s?
Його можна скопіювати і спробувати Думаю, нам треба повернутись буде до нашого сайту. Так він у вас відкрився мабуть, так нове вікно.
Ми. Ж.
То ж воно було?
Чудово. Так, Так, і от наприклад, Ну, після бачите Дно закривається технал на 40 п'ятому.
Рядку з одного рядка Спробуйте Додати ось це так і давайте глянемо що там в нас, вийшло.
От, бачите скопіювалось але нема зображення. Ну, давайте спробуємо вкрасти зображення.
Ось Бачите, воно. У нас на рядку 40 сьомому вони його Ось поставили по шляху. Що це має бути есецс-прегент нам треба це скопіювати ось тут страпло до нашого проекту.
А на картинку.
Так Ага, воно Мабуть, в прикладах. Тому вам треба буде повернутися в папку прикладів.
Його на видиш.
Так? Виходьте з цієї і тут має бути есец. Побачите ось третя папка жаху.
Ано.
Ось вона тут бренд і там нам треба побут страпно давайте його копіюємо і закиньте його в свою чи проект.
Для цього відкрийте бачите, у вас бокові панелі є такі у до Зліва перший елемент зверху.
Ось так. Так. Воно вам вимагає, щоб ви створили папку, з вам аби треба так. Вам треба Мабуть, відкрити повністю папку тому що воно відкрило Мабуть, окремий елемент.
Папку, в якій буде.
То вам треба відкрити папку, де ваш синтаксичний мал файл знаходиться.
А.
Мені В мене просто так ладно. Зараз.
Напевно, на робочий стіл перенесу і там, папку зроблю.
Вдар.
Що тут дали і тепер треба біжу у львові я думаю, повторно відкрито так папку не Файл а татку вам треба.
Так. Фолдер і відкриваєте там когось Нова парк Так, вибрати Е: Чудово.
Повертайтесь в інтаксичному так, коли індекс. Чи вам Мені здається, ви не той скопіювали вам треба ось цей?
Бачити. З пальцями, проджект, споло тому що мені здається, що це ми скопіювали приклад, який був.
Тому Спробуйте повернутися до вашої папки де розташований той індекс до цього.
Там же ж вона поруч просто ну а на серйозно, сюди.
От і так і вам бачите це треба індексичний нас скопіювати до цієї папи на робочому столі.
Не вистачало тут нижче.
Так вам треба я думаю, що його можна видалити або перейменувати в інший е так відміна можете перейменувати ось те, що у вас або замінити таке от чудовий і тепер спробуйте відкрити ось цей факт, що у вас є в цій папці.
Тощо.
А цеонович я вам напевно, заново впеча.
Ні, у вас все правильно було відкрито так вам треба тепер відкрити ось цю папку побачите у вас тут в поволі вказано що ви все ж таки намагаєтесь відкрити спаль шарм-проджак тому вам треба повернутися папку на робочому столі, і відкрити ось цей індексчними.
Ада.
От але так картинка в нас не вантажиться давайте повернемось до віжого сторінку і виправимо цю помилку.
І все одно, чого йшли.
Тут, що у нас стається нам треба знайти Бачите, у нас є цей імідж на 40 сьомому рядку і в нас серце вказується сорс тобто звідки цей фелд так як він в нас на одному рівні, з цією папкою, тому ми можемо просто вказати будстраплога його назв ось так і давайте спробуємо тепер запустити.
Так. Все одно не враховує. Давайте Може Приберіть слеш так Ну, Давайте ще раз.
Спробуємо. Зберігайте бачите Тобто, ми успішно. З вами вкрали частину пострапу з прикладів.
додати так далі. До його опису там якусь інформацію про свою маністрапедію, ага ось я думаю що досить Добре, вийшло бо як вважаєте.
Так, я теж так, думаю, прикольно це можна зберегти і думаю, її ставити у наш сайт блок.
Так Цілком.
А це завжди до хлопців а листача щось не відповідає.
Можливо, Станіслав довелося відійти а потім проблемним зв'язком. Але бачите ви там зробили їм наприклад, основу сайту який вони далі.
Можуть використовувати.
Так.
Можливо у вас є якісь питання стосовно страху. Незрозумілості.
Це Німеччини. Мас. Це зрозуміло.
системи, Тобто Клієнтам Сергій Олексійович вказує я хочу ось такий сайт і ви швиденько можете накидати базуючись на дизайні він не має бути не функціональний на перших етапах тобто там бази даних у вас може бути не підключено але просто перехід по різних сторінках, тобто таку
клієнту. Дуже гарний за виду Функціональний сайт.
Як і клієнт задоволений задоволеним, і тим, що було в початку і тим, яким чином ви перетворили це за допомогою будстрапу воно ще зараз виглядає ну професійно професійно гарні шрифти гарне позиціонування і таке інше.
За збереженням тих наробок що у вас були Дякую.
Так. Ви бачите клієнт задоволений. В нас якийсь базовий приклад сайту.
я бачу якраз у час, вклалась. У нас якраз ще 1 хвилинка. Важливо. Секунд.
30 лишилося можливо Тоді є якісь Запитання незрозумілості.
Так Сергій Олексійович Є питань.
Ні. Питань? Нема?
Трошки. Провести Я думаю у нас в планах. Якраз наступне заняття це планування все ж таки, завдань.
Володимирович.
Буде прийту. Це початок спрента фактично наступний тиждень і ми з вами розподілимо завдання на що нас є тому що знову ж таки, здоров'я Навіщо друга команда на наступному тижні це У нас на 11-20.
Занять вони до точно прокинуться, і ми зможемо з ними попрацювати трошки бо зараз планування, з другої командою неможливе.
оцінювати щоб ними. Не прали забагато але й неправили замало. То візьмемо приблизно 5 завдань, десь ту ж, саму кількість з урахуванням того, що Деякі завдання зараз ще в процесі розробки.
Тим більше що наступний спринт, розрахований вже на 3 тижні а не на 2 як цей перший був.
Тому буде довше набагато ну і далі ми розглянемо з вами більше прикладів з базом даних також як підмкнути підключити безкоштовну базу даних до вашого простого пакету а якусь там безкоштовну базу даних якийсь простенький бакент на пайтині або на інші моменти переглядати цей
мед спробуємо щось створити тобто щоб без таких прикладів, могли будувати вже основу для себе, в незалежності, від того, що ви розробляєте.
Дякую. Павло Володимирович. Дякую. Шановні Колеги Ми Раді були з вами.
Побачити сьогодні і До зустрічі. З кимось ми зустрінемося у вівторок, з усіма іншими.
Розпочинаючи із середи так що на все добре, сподіваюсь, що наступної нашої зустрічі вже нарешті буде весна.
Це точно Дякую. До побачення.
До побачення.